une production du studio SF
bien au sans filtre le podcast on parle
de ce qu'on veut que nous inviter date
site pH Quentin avec moi habituellement
Dom plante y est pas là donc c'est moi
qui fait l'intro tout seul comme un
grand cette semaine sur le Podcast c'est
un réel honneur et un plaisir de
recevoir Geneviève Janson ça fait
plusieurs ça fait plusieurs années que
je veux la recevoir sur le Podcast mais
là enfin il était prête à venir raconter
son histoire pour ceux et celles qui
ignorent en fait qui est Geneviève
Geneviève était une cycliste
internationale double fois championne du
monde junior de vélo sur route qui au
milieu des années 2000 est sorti dans un
scandale en fait de doping sportif donc
elle avait testé positif à un test
anti-dopping et plusieurs années plus
tard mais on a appris en fait que le
doping était la résultante d'une
relation super toxique de violence et de
contrôle avec son coach de l'époque donc
Geneviève qui a eu l'immobilité de venir
ici et d'ouvrir de s'ouvrir complètement
devant nous de raconter son histoire
complète il y a plein à faire qu'on
s'est dit qu'on a dit aujourd'hui
évidemment que j'avais jamais entendu
ailleurs et je crois qu'il y avait
jamais même jamais raconté
publiquement donc c'est un réel Honor
puis je crois que le message pour
n'importe quel parent de d'athlètes ou
n'importe quel athlète en ce moment qui
vit peut-être des situations ça part en
temps celle que Geneviève a vécu durant
sa jeune et courte carrière et bien
c'est important de l'entendre c'est
important de rester sur tout à l'affût
de comportement qui peuvent être jugés
problématique de la part de personnes en
position d'autorité parce que le sport
c'est du sport c'est pour ça que le fun
puis si votre sport il pue le fun pour x
ou y raison qui est externe à votre
propre désir de vouloir pratiquer le
sport il y a quelque chose qui cloche
fait que essayer d'entendre qu'est-ce
qui cloche puis de le raisonner bref tu
vas pour dire que j'aime bien super
généreuse de son temps et aussi de son
histoire et on espère que vous allez
aimer l'écouter autant qu'on a aimé
avoir cette conversation là donc sans
plus attendre bon podcast le podcast de
cette semaine est présenté par la
clinique Biron vous le savez ici au sans
filtre podcast on est des fans d'une
santé sexuelle épanouie et une bonne
santé sexuelle ça commence par un
dépistage avant et après une relation
avec une nouvelle personne la plupart
des maladies infections transmises
sexuellement et par le sang sont souvent
asymptomatiques et c'est pour ça que
c'est important de se faire tester
régulièrement mais je vous entends déjà
dire que se faire tester se faire
dépister c'est compliqué ça prend du
temps ça prend un rendez-vous une
prescription et non détrompez-vous parce
que la clinique Biron offre un dépistage
ITSS sans ordonnance sans délai et
check-ebab et ça sans filtre
c'est le nom du podcast donc allez au
biron.com pour avoir tous les détails
puis vous allez pouvoir
bénéficier en fait d'un dépistage ITSS
en toute autonomie en toute simplicité
et ainsi vivre votre meilleure vie avec
une santé sexuelle épanouie épanouie
épanouie et pas nous une santé sexuelle
épanouie fait que aller voir ça au
bureau.com et merci clinique Biron de
supporter le sans filtre
le podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par nos amis chez manscape qui viennent
de sortir le kit
ultime pour la barbe ici c'est le build
Edge qui est un trimard pour la barbe
puis la chose ultime dans ce produit là
c'est que vous pouvez décider il y a
quand même une petite roulette autour
qui décide la longueur que vous voulez
avoir de votre barbe ça va de 0.5
jusqu'à 10 puis moi c'est un problème
que j'avais parce que on en parlait
souvent je me faisais la barre avec le
[Musique]
4.0 mais là il y avait deux longueurs
seulement ceux-là il y a toutes les
longueurs que vous voulez dans le fond
c'est que là à partir maintenant je vais
pouvoir avoir la barbe idéale tout le
temps c'était pas un million de pièces
que le
non-garde
ce n'est que la longueur idéale puis en
plus de ça en plus de dans le paquet du
build a ça vient avec plein d'autres
affaires d'hommes
je t'engue barre la dedans tu as
vraiment tout ce que tu as besoin pour
avoir la barbe ultime la barbe
toujours de mal one bear rules puis dans
le fond mais on a même une petite marche
à suivre qui est détaillée ici on a tout
ce qu'on a besoin pour laver la barbe on
a un shampoing à barbe après ça on va se
peigner avec ce petit peigne là après ça
on va se
se tendre cette Crimée la barbe à la
longueur idéale avec ceux on se fait une
petite finition au ciseau après ça on la
brosse et on se fait pas mal une petite
tuile qu'elle soit bien
bien lisse et bien placé mais parfaite
donc avec une barbe comme ça ça va
changer votre vie c'est sûr si vous ou
quelqu'un dans votre vie a une barbe
c'est un Game changer honnêtement là
nous on a reçu les trucs le je ramène ça
chez nous définitivement puis ça va être
ma nouvelle routine de barbe puis on a
un code promo pour vous autres qui est
le même code qu'on utilise tout le temps
c'est le sans filtre pour 20% de rabais
et la livraison gratuite sur tous les
produits manscape mais principalement le
nouveau build Edge donc sauter là-dessus
puis oubliez pas du geler le code promo
comme ça ils vont savoir que c'est nous
qui vous envoie c'est bon pour tout le
monde c'est bon pour vous qui avez une
barbe c'est bon pour la personne que
vous connaissez Gavin barbe c'est bon
pour nous c'est bon pour mannequin c'est
bon pour Nicole qui nous écoute en ce
moment c'est bon pour tout le monde ok
code promo sans fil 20% de rabais
livraison gratuite sur télé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la suite de ta lettre ouverte au
comité de cycliste c'est quoi
plusieurs fédérations comme la
communauté olympique et tout mais fac
oui c'est comme le gouvernement du vélo
c'est eux qui font les règlements qui
décident les boissons trop longs avec
quelle sorte de vélo on peut l'aéro le
pyrométrer des blagues mais c'est Lucie
aussi qui rend le sport sécuritaire
c'est donc c'est vraiment notre
gouvernement si on peut dire on
reviendra sur la lettre ouverte
éventuellement mais pourquoi qu'est-ce
qui a changé de ce moment-là je suis
quand même où est-ce que là ça tente de
venir sur sur un podcast c'est une super
bonne question c'est parce que je pense
que dans le temps même si j'ai
longtemps au milieu de la controverse
exactement ça devait être en 2001 parce
que la lettre est sortie me semble le
premier avril 2001 puis
2021 oui c'est ça je pense que
je voulais pas faire de podcast où je
voulais pas vraiment faire l'interview
même si j'étais sorti publiquement avec
cette lettre là qui dénonçait certaines
choses
j'étais pas prête à aller au fond de ma
vérité tu sais j'avais encore trop
d'affaires à l'intérieur des secrets que
je voulais pas dire que je pensais que
j'allais mourir avec enfin que je me
disais ok journaliste un podcast mais ou
une entrevue ou c'est un documentaire
n'importe quoi puis mais j'y réponds au
fond à quoi ça sert
j'active je pense que j'étais plus dans
ce mindset mais oui oui je m'en souviens
mais moi écoute ça fait ça fait
longtemps que
je veux te parler tu sais parce que nous
moi j'ai 32 ans 2031 puis c'est ton
histoire
marquée parce qu'on était des des fans
de sport puis au Québec évidemment ça a
été vraiment gros mais on dirait que ça
fera pas
ou du moins moi ça me fera pas encore
plus que mes amis qui faisaient pas de
sport mais toi aussi ça a tellement été
gros dans mon imaginaire parce que ça
faisait longtemps que que je voulais te
parler puis quand on a eu le podcast
c'était une belle occasion de le faire
c'est que je suis content merci d'être
là
mais la question était quand même bonne
en fait qu'est-ce qui a changé exact
depuis
dans le fond je me jette là c'était
comme une première étape pour toi puis
que depuis ce moment-là j'imagine que
une étape à la fois peut-être que il y a
cheminement qui se fait ou oui c'est sûr
qu'il y a un cheminement personnel puis
tu sais moi j'ai j'ai commencé à
consulter
quand j'étais aux États-Unis quand je me
suis finalement sauvée de mon entraîneur
donc environ en 2006
mais si c'est comme une petite pleure à
la fois donc au début là tu dis pas
grand chose tu travailles sur le
problème qui est le plus présent ou
qu'est-ce qui donne le plus d'anxiété et
puis finalement quand tu t'es assez
confortable là-dedans mais c'est l'autre
tu t'attaques au plus gros au chose
enfin que c'est sûr qu'il y a une
croissance personnelle que j'ai faite
là-dedans puis j'ai compris beaucoup de
choses de qu'est-ce qui m'est arrivé le
pourquoi et tout ça puis surtout que ça
a pas de ma faute mais je dois donner le
crédit à mon chum que tu par respect
pour lui si tu t'en vas dans une
relation avec quelqu'un que vécu des
abus tu sais il faut que la personne le
sache moi j'ai tout le temps été dans
cette dans ce mindset
Paul c'est ce qui m'est arrivé et puis
c'est tout ça enfin que lui en sachant
toute qu'est-ce qui m'est arrivé et
comment que le dopage finalement faisait
partie c'était quasiment la plus petite
des violations qui me sont arrivés ici
et puis il était là John il y a personne
qui connaissait il y a personne qui va
comprendre qu'est-ce qui est arrivé si
tu parles pas de toute qu'est-ce que
c'est passé avant
de travailler puis travailler puis ça
fait longtemps qu'il me dit ça fait
depuis le début qu'on est ensemble puis
là mais avec la lettre ouverte c'est
peut-être le premier pas puis après ça
je me suis rendu compte que ça pouvait
ça pourrait faire du bien à plusieurs
athlètes puis là ben éventuellement j'ai
décidé d'y aller en ligne
puis voilà puis dans le fond la lettre
ouverte en tant que tel juste pour
remettre en contexte il y avait un si je
me rappelle bien il y avait un
entraîneur qui sévissait en termes
d'abus autant physique que
en Europe en Europe
puis toi il y avait pas de de
sanctions qui étaient donnés encore mais
il y a eu une sanction mais c'est hyper
cool ça a été super cool la sanction est
un rétroactive en plus factice
en mai 2022 mais le premier six mois
la sanction a été donnée en mai 2022
mais ils l'ont décidé de le sanctionner
depuis décembre déjà 5 mois de fête à
quoi ça sert mais toi ce que tu disais
juste pour remettre en contexte mais
après tu me diras si c'est vraiment ça
si ma mémoire est bonne mais ce que tu
disais c'était lui il y a ça puis moi
j'ai 10 ans pour du dopping qui est au
final le résultat d'une chaîne
d'événement d'abus
c'est pas faux mais ma lettre était
surtout sur le fait comment pour
dénoncer comment ça avait été
maltraité donc il y a eu 11 jeunes
femmes qui ont fait des plaintes et on
fait des plaintes à Lucio comité éthique
le comité éthique a pris environ
6 9 mois là je m'en souviens plus là
pour trop longtemps trop longtemps pour
faire leur investigation les jeunes
femmes qui ont décidé de parler ont été
tenus dans le néant il savait pas en
tout cas ce qu'elle arrivait avec leur
cas il a été point informé des
développements et tout donc une fois que
le comité d'éthique a dit ok il y a
vraiment une faute qui a été commises
ils l'ont mis au comité disciplinaire le
comité disciplinaire a repris un autre x
moi pour donner la sanction qui est une
sanction rétroactive mais supposons ça
ça le prix deux ans de temps pendant
deux ans le gars il y a continué à
travailler dans le plateau féminin
tactile ils abus qui faisaient
ça ça a continué enfin si j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment
malsain pour les jeunes femmes puis je
me suis dit si ça continue comme ça il y
aura pas personne qui va décider de
parler parce que c'est puis on voit ça
souvent dans la société il dit le paper
work la bureaucratie est tellement
grande que finalement les gens disent
Maga ça vaut même pas la peine enfin que
c'est un petit peu ça que je dénonçais
en même temps ben là j'ai parlé de mon
expérience personnelle c'est que pour
moi oui j'ai pris des produits dopants
mais j'en ai pris pour la première fois
à 16 ans puis c'était la conséquence
d'avoir été abusé sexuellement
émotionnellement psychologiquement
physiquement c'est tout ça c'est juste
la suite de ça
a commencé
à ton histoire
est-ce que pendant en fait quand
premièrement est-ce que quand ça
arrivait tu t'en rendais compte parce
que j'imagine que c'est pernicieux c'est
quelque chose qui arrive progressivement
puis là au début tu es comme tu acceptes
des affaires puis tu en accepte de plus
en plus mais au-dessus mettons je sais
pas la première fois que tu t'es dopé
est-ce que tu réalisais ce que ce qui
est en train de se passer mais tant que
tu réalisais
pas cool c'est pas correct ce qui
m'arrive ou tu es comme trop dedans
encore mais pour moi de la façon que
c'était arrivé mais tu sais j'ai gagné
quand même plusieurs courses sans dopage
là dont les deux médailles d'or au
Championnat canadien quand j'étais
encore dans le cadet puis si j'avais été
surclassé dans les championnats dans les
juniors enfin que j'ai gagné tout ça
quand j'étais cadette mais
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé en premier
comment ça ça a commencé c'était la
violence s'il y a même frapper des
entraînements il y a la même crier après
utiliser l'entraînement comme punition
en fait mais il était super
violente la claque à l'arrivée vite puis
il me disait tout le temps
parce que quand tu es dans au
championnat du monde toutes les filles
sont en ligne bon de la forte puis
c'était capable de prendre ma violence
tu vas être capable de prendre les coups
de compétition genre les attaques tu vas
être capable de répondre
ok
c'est le premier coach que j'ai eu
vraiment
je vois de plus en plus vite c'est mes
compétitions ça va bien je renforcis
tout de suite ok
la première la première année se passe
sans dopage sans rien avec lui
je l'ai rencontré quand j'avais 13 mais
c'est ma première année de vrai
entraînement
enfin que en première année se passe les
abus continuent c'est la violence tout
de suite
je me faisais tout le temps je suis
cannée
que mon entraînement soit bon ou pas
si je pouvais comprendre je sais comment
que oui ça se peut parce que c'est vrai
que dans une course
des fois dans les plots des affaires de
même pour avoir fait du sport je veux
dire des fois les couches sont raides
puis c'est ce que je veux dire c'est pas
nécessairement mal simple
il y a une forme de de de de de raideur
de motivation ou de type de juste de qui
peut être bénéfique pour pousser un
athlète mais puis après ça c'est démêler
tout seul aujourd'hui
si tu étais en train de planter ton
entraînement et puis tu fais n'importe
quoi puis tu es pas concentré il faut
que ton coach soit on vient de te voir
petit écoute c'est là tu votre énergie
aux poubelles parce que ça leur corps
qu'est-ce que tu fais c'est une place
pour être stricte ça c'est certain puis
je crois encore aujourd'hui que si tu
veux gagner des médailles aux Jeux
olympiques ou même oublier ça les Jeux
Olympiques le même arrivé au top de ta
performance à toi individuel ça peut
être 100e 500e au monde si tu veux
arriver à ton plein potentiel il faut un
moment donné que tu ailles un coach qui
soit assez strict c'est ça
parce que moi mettons cet exemple en
tout cas moi j'ai eu un coach assez
strict dans dans ma vie puis moi ça
marchait pas me faire crier après le tir
moi ça marchait pas du genre juste me
faire ça fonctionnait pas fermé c'est
j'aurais préféré qu'il vienne me voir
face ce que tu viens de dire là tu
jettes ton énergie aux poubelle en ce
moment ce que tu fais ça sert à rien
juste me l'expliquer
ça fonctionnait mais moi je me rends
compte non plus que ça marchait pas avec
moi
mais si pour en revenir à la chronologie
des affaires la violence est arrivée
puis un moment donné il est arrivé une
période où est-ce que là il m'a dit
tiens l'amour avec toi
si tu me laisses je vais me suicider si
tu me laisses c'est comme comme coach tu
décides d'aller prendre un autre coach
ou moi je demande je vais te retrouver
je vais te tuer puis après je me suis
décidé ça me dérange pas je peux pas
vivre sans toi
15 ans
si tu sais parler manipulation à l'école
mettons il donne cet exemple si tu me
quittes je me suicide
comme tu veux pas vivre avec le suicide
de quelqu'un sur tes épaules et puis je
sais pas quand j'avais 15 ans écoute en
1995-85 c'était pas hyper ouvert sur ça
ça commence puis
après ben là je t'avais qu'un coach qui
qui est en amour avec moi puis qui va se
suicider si je décide de le quitter puis
en plus de ça avec les abus que je viens
de vivre je peux pas les dire à personne
parce que là je me sens hyper sale puis
je sens que c'est de ma faute si je vais
aller dire ça à qui mes parents genre je
voulais pas dire ça à personne enfin que
je me suis juste dit puis je m'en
souviens dans ce livre tu diras avec ça
après c'était trop gros pour moi j'étais
en secondaire
après ça ben lui il a décidé il était
prof de Jim en plus en tout cas il
décède qui laisse son emploi
votre relation j'imagine qu'il est tout
le temps là tout le temps partout t'es
jamais toute seule tu peux te jamais de
moments de ou que Paul l'emprise sur toi
justement au cours c'est tout le temps
là il m'appelait le soir en plus après
les entraînements si je veux dire
j'étais allé ma journée à l'école je
m'étais entraîné avec lui après j'avais
juste le temps d'arriver chez nous de
souper de finir mes devoirs puis après
je comprenais pas qu'est-ce qu'il
voulait me dire au téléphone il passait
une heure avec mon téléphone puis des
fois on disait rien si j'étais juste là
au bout du fil puis c'était comme un
contrôle extrême mais en même temps je
me disais je suis quand même chanceuse
parce que j'ai un coach qui s'occupe
juste de moi s'il me le disait il y a
pas un autre petite fille là qui a des
coachs comme moi qui vont aller en
voyage avec toi qui vont être là à
toutes les courses regarde tu vois tu es
en voiture il y en avait pas est-ce que
est-ce que à ce moment-là il y a des
gens qui gravitent autour de toi qui
essaient parce que tu mettons mettons
que je fais un parallèle quand il
boiteux le métier mettons un ami que
dans une relation malsaine tu essayes
ton affaire et mais tu le vois pas quand
tu es dedans puis tu sais est-ce que toi
il y a des gens qui ont essayé de te
parler mais que tu voulais pas
l'entendre
puis je tenais fait m'entraîner là c'est
de la merde je fais plus rien enfin qui
me dit ben là John on peut pas y aller
avec la route normale prendre du repos
prendre les suppléments de fer parce que
moi j'ai pas de job c'est là on est
rendu au mois de mai juin ta saison
c'est en train de plus tu reposes oublie
ça là on n'aura pas d'argent tout seul
puis il me dit ben si je connais médecin
on va t'amener voir le médecin puis il
va te donner ça puis on va partir ça
sera pas beaucoup pour commencer puis
après ça on va te remettre sur pied ça
va capable d'être entraîner ça étant le
pays
qui donne ça ce que tu sais ce que c'est
est-ce que tu sais c'est quoi
je sais qu'il y a pas de test
en même temps moi je suis trop pris dans
il va il va se suicider
de suivre ce qui dit le plus possible
pour m'attirer le moins de problèmes
puis là mais je m'en vais chez le
médecin je reçois ma première injection
puis après ça c'était fini si j'étais
déjà embarqué dans la rue puis après ça
le jamais arrêté là enfin que
là je me retrouve à 16 ans
j'étais une criminelle dans le monde
dans lequel je vis parce que dans le
monde du sport c'est tu as pas le droit
de faire des de prendre la prod c'est
comme si tu prends l'athlète dans son
monde de sport puis tu le transposes en
société mais quelqu'un qui fait des
affaires égales
j'ai vécu plein d'abus que je peux pas
dire à personne je peux pas aller
chercher un autre coach
parce que là je prends déjà des produits
dopants
tu pleures mes performances descendent
le coach va être comme qu'est-ce qui se
passe je peux pas aller voir ma
fédération parce que la Fédération au
lieu de m'aider ou l'union spéciale
parce qu'au lieu de m'aider ils vont me
bannir de mon sport et on me donne un
section puis j'ai encore des rêves si je
veux encore être champion du monde je
vais aller aux Olympiques à 5 ans je
savais je vais aller aux yeux olympiques
la seule personne qui connaît ce secret
là c'est ton agresseur finalement avec
lui c'est un pouvoir de plus que sur toi
c'est exact mais qu'est-ce qui m'a fait
rester le plus longtemps puis maintenant
que si je comprends le Patton des femmes
battues qui restent dans ses relations
là pendant ils parlent longtemps
c'est que
tu veux pas avoir mal moi je voulais pas
que je suicide non plus en même temps
quitter ses relations là c'est là que
c'est le plus dangereux c'est parce que
c'est souvent quand tu quittes ou quand
tu dis que tu veux quitter que là c'est
la fille assassiner
puis quand je me suis sauvé de sa
relation là aussi ça les presque tourner
à ça mais finalement non si j'ai été
chanceux dans ma malchance enfin que
mais c'est le les menaces de me faire
qui allait me retrouver puis me tuer
puis que lui qui suicide qui m'ont le
plus longtemps ça c'est resté avec toi
le tout le temps aujourd'hui c'est lui
qui est encore en vie est aux États-Unis
c'est con à dire mais j'ai encore peur
de qui meurtv qui reviennent puis que je
le rencontre où c'est qu'il m'arrive
quelque chose pour que ça soit lui
puis ce à partir le moment qui dit il
faut vraiment que je sorte de cette
emprise le puis au moment où finalement
les événements font que tu sors de ce
relation là c'est beaucoup d'années
le scandale tu avais quoi 25 et 24 25
ans 24 ans je pense que j'ai testé
positif en 2005 je mets ma sanction en
2006 j'ai fait le choix avec Ravel 2006
2007 je pense et 2007 là mais on faisait
la chronologie type tu te racontes les
premières fois les premières agressions
la violence les débuts de de 9 le pays
mais ce qu'il faut c'est beaucoup
d'années
mais je veux dire c'est c'est des années
de calvaire finalement il y a une longue
année
j'ai appris vraiment à
me rétrécir comme personne puis tu sais
à jamais rien dire puis à penser que
toute c'est de ma faute
mobilier complètement hâté vraiment
m'effacer de la société là il fascie qui
je suis ou perdre le contact avec
vous si je sentais tout le temps dans ce
temps-là qui avait une deuxième personne
en moi que je pouvais pas être puis je
me disais souvent j'étais comme je peux
pas vivre de même si mais je savais pas
comment m'en sortir mais en même temps
je faisais un peu confiance à la vie tu
sais je savais que éventuellement il y a
l'arrivée un moment que je serais
capable sauf que dans dans mon day to
day là je me disais pense pas dire avec
ça plus tard dès que la conséquence plus
tard plus tard plus tard c'est juste
vraiment de la survie de jour en jour le
titre que j'essayais le plus possible de
faire
parce que la dynamique toujours empirée
ou à ma liste ça atteint un plat un
plateau
un plateau puis ça leur restait comme ça
pour longtemps c'est
un plateau horribles
est-ce que tu trouvais encore
du plaisir à être sur ton vélo parce que
moi dans l'histoire je t'entendais sur
un podcast
je me rappelle plus du nom mais que tu
disais que
tu prenais plus de fan à au sport puis
c'est ça qui me faisait qui m'a comme
touché le plus je me disais c'est nous
ici au podcast on parle souvent du sport
comme étant une façon de genre faire un
greak reset quand il y a quand il y a de
la marde dans ta vie quand ça va pas
bien tu vas faire du sport
tu avais pas tu t'échappatoire là du
tout mais j'avais pas échappatoire là
puis j'avais pas d'autres non plus si
j'allais plus aller
5 j'ai arrêté
je suis retournée après là j'ai fait mon
cégep j'avais 30 ans mais si j'avais pas
de job j'avais pas j'avais pas d'amis
j'avais pas le droit de voir personne
j'avais pas le droit de sortir tout seul
les clés du genre étaient cachés
factice ça allait mal dans mon
entraînement
c'est juste ça je pensais puis dans ma
journée c'est je pouvais pas dire ok je
m'en vais sur une raille de bail que je
m'en vais courir dans trail puis
maintenant c'est ce que je vis ici je
veux une vraie job puis bon j'ai des
amis je suis quand même assez balancé et
puis là c'est là que je vois le sport
comment que ça peut aider à te faire des
WC tu reviens de ton entraînement que tu
es comme tu sens que tu peux tout faire
dans vie c'est même quand on est super
dur puis tu as des tempos tu as des
intervalles et tout tu reviens d'adopes
tu es comme ok regarde non j'avais pas
ça dans le temps puis c'était rendu
ça tellement sérieux puis j'avais
tellement peur
parce qu'à toutes les fois tu sais
pendant 10 ans j'ai appris que que je
fasse un bon entraînement ou un mauvais
entraînement il va rendre conséquence
puis les conséquences étaient pires
quand les entraînements étaient pas bons
taxi je suis sûr que tu vis ça aussi là
tu regardes ton programme tu sais une
semaine à l'avance plus tu regardes ne
ta journée ça aussi
mais comment je vais faire passer au
travail moi je voyais ça là celle-là je
voyais ma séance du samedi puis j'étais
tellement stressée toute la semaine que
là les entraînements que j'avais dans
semaine j'avais de la misère à les faire
mais j'ai faisais pareil puis là
j'arrive au samedi puis ça là ça
marchait pas enfin que les conséquences
étaient
la thématique de mon entraînement
c'était ce souvent affecté non j'en
avais pas de fan je pense c'est un petit
peu pour ça aussi en grosse partie
pourquoi j'ai décidé que je reprenais à
la compétition à 40 ans là parce que
j'en parle avec plein de monde puis
plein de jeunes femmes cyclistes sont
comme c'est tellement cool pour
s'entraîner
vous avez du fun
il faut que je vive ça je peux pas finir
ma carrière d'athlète même si
j'irai plus au niveau où est-ce que
j'étais pas finir ce sans avoir eu de
fun ça c'est complètement stupide là
j'ai tellement pas assez de temps dans
ma vie puis j'aimais ça avant le vélo
aussi ça sorti de moi là c'est pas je me
suis pas fait imposer ça par mes parents
mes parents ils font même pas de sport
c'est ma carte maintenant de redécouvrir
le plaisir
ça doit être un ajustement de thé un
moment c'était tellement longtemps dans
ta vie ou tout était géré pour toi ou tu
étais jamais justement tu prenais jamais
une décision par toi-même finalement le
titre tout était c'était quoi en fait de
devenir
un peu de jours au lendemain un humain
qui doit comme s'occuper de lui-même
dans la société il prend ses propres
décisions se débrouiller ça doit être un
choc immense c'était vraiment un
accident de train mais qu'est-ce qui m'a
sauvé je pense c'est que
quand j'ai quand j'ai eu ma sanction moi
j'ai toujours rêvé d'avoir un restaurant
pendant une éternité quand je cours
sèche alors moi je veux un bar je vais
avoir de la bière j'ai vraiment des vins
si je vais avoir des c'était vraiment le
bouffe bistrot de quartier ou un petit
pas ou quelque chose c'était vraiment ça
qui m'a allumé c'est dans mon after
quand j'ai eu ma sanction je sais
comment il faut que je fasse de quoi tu
sais je suis aux États-Unis mais là
quand t'es athlète c'est plus facile le
reste aux États-Unis mais une fois que
tu les pues tu as besoin d'un visa pour
rester là je voulais rester là parce que
j'aurais fait au Québec c'est qui aurait
voulu être associé à une fille qui vient
d'échouer un test de dopage personne
m'aurait donné job j'aurais peut-être
retourné à l'école mais pour faire quoi
si je me sentais vraiment
corner
enfin que je me suis dit mais là je suis
aux États-Unis j'ai une maison là-bas
c'est j'ai un petit peu d'argent mis de
côté je m'achète un restaurant j'ai
acheté le restaurant
puis j'ai commencé à travailler tout de
suite dedans
puis quand ma première journée que je
m'en souviendrai tout le temps si
j'étais encore un peu en arrière puis
lui c'est sûr qui est encore là c'est
pas avec le test de dopage positif qui
est sorti de ma vie parce qu'il
contrôlait aussi les finances et tout ça
active lui si vous voulez rester aux
États-Unis non enfin que puis lui il
s'est poignée avec une employée du
restaurant qui est pas surprenable mais
à le décider car quitter on the spot la
restaurant est à plein c'est un dimanche
c'est une zone avec comme j'avais une
place qui était déjeuné du nez il y
avait une file de monde dehors puis elle
a décidé de Cassandra parce que le boss
ça n'en peut plus là c'est un ensemble
je connais même pas les assiettes rien
la section est pleine je m'en souviens
là comme c'était hier je suis rentré
dans le Working j'étais tellement
stressé j'avais tellement je suis que
quand je suis arrivée dans le Working
mais shorts ont gelé je reste là comme 5
minutes parce que je vérifie deux dans
un frigidaire et géant
c'est soit que tu disparais dans le
bureau tu fais rien ou tu sors tu prends
les assiettes puis tu dis au monde genre
je suis désolé gagne est-ce que ça va
ici dire j'avais mes numéros de table
j'avais mon plan de salle je savais où
aller mais là le restant j'avais qu'une
idée puis le temps que ça m'a pris pour
prendre la décision je suis sortie du
walking chez l'homme et chaudière parce
qu'il était mouillé là j'avais su
au travers de mes short c'est pas
finalement j'ai fait mon premier chiffre
puis c'était tout croche l'autre mais ça
ça a été mon premier comme ok je suis
capable de faire ça pour le lendemain
j'ai pris sa place puis j'apprécie j'ai
travaillé à tous les jours c'est moi qui
ouvrait j'ai travaillé à tous les jours
après dans le restaurant puis ça la
restauration ça a commencé la vie parce
que c'est la première expérience que
j'ai eu où est-ce que un mes clients me
connaissait pas du tout ils savaient pas
qu'est-ce qui m'est arrivé qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans ma vie puis il m'aimait
pour moi le matin et puis il venait me
parler je sais pas me parler de leurs
problèmes tu sais mais je leur servais
du café filtre
n'avait aucune idée c'est ça à faire
de l'argent j'avais mes titres là ok si
je peux faire de quoi tu te rends compte
que tu peux avoir une valeur excellence
vélo finalement exactement tu peux
participer j'ai rencontré j'ai commencé
à rencontrer mais pas rencontré des
clients là tu sais mais j'avais des gars
qui rentrait
avec ce gosse ce serait cool
si je veux cette vie là si je veux avoir
un vrai chat
je peux pas rester avec lui ça marchera
jamais c'est un oui ça marche pas là je
vais pas rester là-dedans puis deux là
j'ai un moyen de gagner ma vie parce que
je peux travailler en restauration et je
peux avoir de l'argent je peux me louer
un appartement
c'est vraiment ça qui m'a
partie sur sur mes deux pieds mais
pendant longtemps j'ai pensé quand je
vais je vais me sauver de lui quand on
sera plus ensemble quand je vais voir ma
vie toute va devenir
magiquement magnifique tout d'un coup
je parle le vendredi ma vie c'est de la
merde puis le samedi je me sauve j'ai ma
place où j'habite chez un ami peut-être
le Hot d'un coup le waouh c'est John
c'est que everything
non non oh my god ça m'a pris un petit
je pourrais dire j'ai peut-être même pas
encore arrivé là à beaucoup beaucoup de
temps après à 41 ans maintenant mais
c'est ça m'a pris une éternité ça m'a
pris au moins
deux ans avant de
d'aller voir dans les consulter
d'avoir un semblant de
quoi faire comment prendre soin de moi
quoi faire quand je triche quoi faire
quand j'ai quand je vais avoir du fun
qu'est-ce que j'ai de besoin dans cette
émission là ou rien
rien rien
j'ai été aux États-Unis
indépendance là c'est sûr que mes
parents voulaient que je reviens dans la
maison et vous la m'aider mais j'étais
pas capable d'accepter de l'aide je veux
dire comme tu as dit tantôt j'avais
tellement pas pris de décision dans ma
vie que je me disais oui tu sais ce
serait cool aller chez mum puis dad là
dormez dans mon ancienne chambre il part
de facture à payer puis rien de ça avoir
mon repas prêt et puis mon linge lavé
puis tout ça mais j'étais là
je veux pas me fasser quoi faire je peux
pas il faut vraiment que je vive
mais
après dans le fond c'est moi j'avais
comme je sais pas pourquoi j'avais
imaginé que le jour où ta carrière était
finie cette relation là c'est terminé
mais finalement c'est pas ça du tout
mais puis tu parles de quantité quantité
sauvée mais ça ça a été ça a pris
combien de temps et puis comment ça
s'est fait ce moment-là j'ai testé
positif en 2005 à la fin de l'été 2005
je l'ai appris genre septembre parce que
je peux aller au Championnat du Monde
puis j'étais en shape cette année-là tu
sais j'aurais eu j'aurais bien fait au
championnat du monde
je l'ai appris en 2005 j'ai acheté le
restaurant en 2006 au printemps 2016
genre avril
puis je me suis sauvé au mois d'août de
la même année
faxa pris comme un an
ge littéral
parce que comme j'ai dit je pouvais pas
vraiment sortir par moi-même là
j'allais ouvrir le restaurant Le Matin
et puis j'étais seule je faisais mon
chef lui rentrait l'après-midi pour
compter la crise
pour être sûr que je vais pas pris
d'argent à son insu puis tout ça puis
après ça ben je rentrais chez nous c'est
le lendemain matin on ouvrait les autres
le restaurant ouvrir à 6h j'étais quand
même assez loin à 3h30 du matin j'étais
debout à 4h30 j'étais parti j'arrive à
la 5h sans préparer la salle et tout de
suite j'avais pas vraiment de vie puis
je savais que ça serait impossible
d'avoir une discussion
enfin que un moment donné je me suis
réveillé un matin puis comme claire
c'est les yeux ouverts
aujourd'hui ça se passe aujourd'hui je
sais pas d'où c'est sorti mais quand je
cerveau restaurant j'ai appelé une de
mes amis filles qui était québécoise qui
habitait en Arizona ça faisait super
longtemps puis elle savait pas qu'est-ce
qui se passait mais elle le connaissait
parce qu'elle avait grandi avec lui
puis il y a sa vie un peu c'est à s'en
douter enfin que j'avais j'ai dit je les
écoute je peux tu venir au restaurant à
deux heures cet après-midi je pense que
là il faut que je m'en aille c'est bien
tu es comme John parfait je vais être là
deux heures il lui rentre un petit peu
avant si on a encore la salle est pleine
de clients qui finissent leur loge et
tout ça puis je commence à y parler et
puis je dis écoute là c'est fini moi je
m'en veux je veux plus qu'on habite
ensemble je veux plus qu'on soit
ensemble je vais plus qu'on a le
restaurant ensemble je veux vraiment ma
vie à moi et là lui explose comment
s'acheter des assiettes à terre me crier
après les clients savent plus quoi faire
dans le restaurant c'est dans le resto
dans le restaurant tout le monde comme
si il y avait rien qui existait puis
dans l'entrefit puis le restaurant était
grand le j'avais 155 places donc moi
j'étais au bout de la je suis au bout de
un bout de la salle puis il y a des
vitrées tout autour puis je la vois
arriver qui ouvre la porte
puis en même temps lui se retourne la
voix puis me dit John et du vieille
temps en arrière avec moi je vais te
parler tout seul puis elle est dans le
porte pierre vas-y pas vas-y pas il faut
que tu me suives et j'ai pas aimé ma
sacoche on a j'ai couru au travail il
pouvait pas m'arrêter là
j'ai couru on était embarqué dans son
char parti le moteur lui est sorti du
restaurant Il nous courait après bien
mais finalement on on est parti puis la
première question qu'on m'a demandé tu
as comme tu as un compte de banque juste
à ton nom
à dire ok on s'en va t'ouvrir un compte
de banque enfin que j'ai pris la moitié
de l'argent qui avait dans le compte je
l'ai mis dans je me souviens un compte à
moi tout seul je restais là c'était le
soir là chez elle puis pendant toute la
tirade là qu'on a eu la chicane dans le
restaurant il me disait je dois brûler
ton demain matin tu en auras plus je
vais mettre une bombe dedans et puis
blablabla
la soirée à appeler mon ami de fille
puis appeler voir où est-ce qu'elle est
puis elle a dit écoute je sais pas moi
je l'ai amené à telle place puis après
ça je sais pas si elle est partie avec
un nom un gars ou un ami ou c'est
n'importe quoi
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai
le lendemain matin c'est sûr que je peux
rentrer travailler puis j'ai eu j'ai
appelé ma cousine au Québec qui que là
elle aussi elle avait été appelée par
lui pour savoir si je l'avais appelé ou
est-ce que j'étais petite
il y avait ouvert finalement pas brûler
là il y a pas mis les bombes dedans
quand j'ai vu ça
il y a peut-être sale mais ça allait
quand j'ai vu ça j'ai je me suis dit ok
ça c'est mon windows c'est ma fenêtre
d'opportunité pour retourner à la maison
que j'avais pu prendre les affaires mais
j'étais tellement stressé qui arrive
pendant que j'étais que je voulais pas y
vivre seul de fille à habiter avec un
goût et super fin là
avec moi et dis oui pas de problème
enfin qu'on parle puis le chalet
qu'est-ce que je dois faire si il a
changé les serrures tu peux pas entrer
comme jeune mais ton nom et sur le bail
à la maison tu sais sur le
certificat chez vous oui c'est ma maison
ok donc on rentre il y avait pas changé
serrure je me suis pris une valise puis
je pense encore c'est mon quand je suis
aux olympique ils m'ont donné une grosse
valise là comme tu es une Canada rouge
j'ai mis le plus à faire que je pouvais
là-dedans je partais avec ça mon bike et
je ne suis plus jamais retourné après ça
toutes nos discussions sont faites avec
un avocat parce que là on avait la
maison ensemble on avait le restaurant
ensemble tout de suite pour tout diviser
ça
puis tout le temps
qu'il y a pas pu être garder son son
emprise sa manipulation après ça si je
mets là des fois je me dis oui j'ai
encore peur qu'il me retrouve c'est mais
s'il y avait eu à me retrouver il aurait
fait dans ce temps-là parce que bon j'ai
après ça j'ai je suis resté je suis une
coupe de mes amis différentes personnes
jusqu'à temps que je me trouve une place
à moi
puis moi j'ai dit c'est là écoute moi je
mens je vais plus travailler avec toi on
va vendre le restaurant si on va voir le
restaurant Toi tu pars ton visa moi je
pars mon visa aussi parce qu'on avait
deux visas d'investisseur pour avoir la
Business là-bas que lui il voulait pas
revenir au Québec
puis faites lui a acheté ma page
restaurant enfin que j'ai pu avoir c'est
comme un petit peu d'argent mes côtés
puis j'ai commencé à faire ma vie mon
États-Unis il y a quelque chose de quand
même
poétique dans l'idée de mettre ton stock
dans ta valise Équipe Canada partir avec
ta valise des Olympiques plus ton break
partir avec ça on dirait qu'il y a une
image qui est quand même forte mais
pendant super longtemps tu sais je te
dirais ça fait juste une coupe d’année
que là je me sens chez moi mais pendant
longtemps j'avais oui j'ai eu d'autres
mais un autre maison après ça mais si
j'avais pas de décoration dedans j'avais
absolument rien quand je suis revenu au
Canada en 2012 j'avais une valise
cariane puis j'avais un sac à dos ça
c'était toutes mes possessions puis je
me promenais 24 heures sur 24 avec mon
passeport parce que je me disais si je
veux m'en aller s'il faut que je me
sauve j'étais dans ce mindset là
et je vais pouvoir la faire si j'ai rien
je peux attaché à rien j'ai mon
passeport j'ai du cash en banque s'il
faut que je disparaisse
parce que j'avais tout le temps un petit
peu peur
si demain matin il faut juste pareil
ouais quand même au milieu de
controverse là c'est juste même quand
j'ai rencontré mon chum c'est j'ai
j'étais en colocation avec des filles on
était sur Parc Avenue puis c'était super
cool mais c'est dans ma chambre j'avais
rien puis pas il était là mais tu peux
pas j'avais même pas de rideaux dans ma
fenêtre
il était 43 heures du matin faisait noir
si je me couchais peut-être je me
réveillais pas là avec le soleil le
matin
comment tu fais pour vivre mes
confortable j'étais bien finalement mon
chat même ça décorer fait qu'on
sur le qui-vive à bouger pendant une
éternité ça tout le temps était
totalement en mode survie longtemps
j'imagine que ça a jamais été
quelque chose comme décoré c'est comme
quand même plus loin dans la liste des
des besoins du monde à l'université ça
fait quatre ans qui sont partis
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui est quand
est-ce que tu dis le je suis prête à
tourner au Québec en fait
[Musique]
dans ma thérapie où est-ce que je me
rendais compte que j'avais fait le tour
c'est toutes les trucs que j'avais à
travailler de base sur moi-même était
faite
pendant longtemps j'ai été fâché contre
mes parents que tu mes parents ils ont
aucune faute là dedans non plus parce
que les autres aussi se sont faites en
fait par la route
en même temps je veux dire il voulait
pas m'empêcher de vivre mon rêve
et puis j'étais jamais là je partais de
chez eux j'avais comme 17 à 17 ans
j'étais aux États-Unis je revenais au
jardin chez mes parents pour comme un
mois la par année plus je mettais mon
plus beau sourire le thé c'est sûr que
je voulais pas qu'est-ce qui s'inquiète
et tout
façon il était complètement blindsided
mais je me rends compte que dans San
Diego j'ai quitté Phoenix en 2008 je
restais j'ai habité à San Diego jusqu'en
j'ai fait une formation San Diego je
voulais retourner à l'école si je
commençais à y repenser tout seul je me
disais j'aimerais savoir plus 15
secondes à 5 parce que j'ai toujours
aimé l'école j'étais toujours bonne j'ai
été j'avais une affinité pour étudier
j'aimais ça fait que j'ai fait une
formation de dans un certificat en
touristique out donc massothérapie et
c'est plus grand que juste massothérapie
j'ai bien aimé ça plus je me suis dit si
je continue à grandir comme personne il
faut que je revienne au Québec il faut
que je vois mes parents il faut que je
travaille sur cette relation là si je
vais avoir des enfants je veux pas
qu'aille pas de grands-parents c'est
j'étais prête à aller
boucler des boucles
de revenir ici
mon style de vie
j'appréhendais pas les gens qui soient
méchants avec moi si j'avais pas peur de
ça
j'avais pas peur de rencontrer mes
parents tu sais mais je me disais c'est
fucking black le Québec si j'étais bien
aux États-Unis j'ai aimé ça j'ai
toujours eu en fait je suis vraiment
content depuis que la balle quand Donald
Trump a été élu j'étais là yes
canadienne québécoise mais dans ce
temps-là j'avais un super beau mode de
vie j'avais plein de bons amis j'étais
avec des gens intéressants entourés déjà
intéressant puis mon souvenir du Québec
c'était pas ça c'est mon souvenir du
Québec c'était toujours d'être critiqué
ou d'être mis comme ennemi avec Line ou
tu sais être reconnu juste pour ma
performance pour les gens voyaient pas
comme une être humain il me voyait comme
un athlète qui me performe c'est tout le
monde me demandait tout le temps sur ma
carrière et puis tu vas bien sentir que
ta course je comprends c'est ça qu'on
fait avec des athlètes mais que c'est ça
mon souvenir tu sais que j'avais c'est
le mode de vie qui me tentait pas
mais finalement je suis revenu puis là
je me suis dit si je veux faire mon
cégep
c'était dans le temps de la grève du
Cégep à chalet dans un sujet privé moi
j'ai fait mon standard au Collège
Sainte-Anne à la chaîne puis maintenant
il y avait un cégep Jacques j'ai été
hyper bien accueilli mais c'est le tu
fais tes sciences nature puis tu es avec
des 17 ans moi ça faisait depuis j'avais
16 ans que je parlais à l'école pitié
j'avais eu des bonnes notes à l'école le
directeur du Cégep il me dit ok on va
juste rentrer dans la session qui est là
puis tu vas être correct c'est le cours
de physique électricité magnétique puis
tu vas en chimie 1 puis bio 1 plutôt
de 56
j'arrive dans les cours de la physique
c'est puis moi j'ai toujours eu
du 90 à l'école jamais ça j'étudiais le
j'adorais ça j'ai adoré les séances
j'adore la qu'en fait si j'avais un
autre affaire à faire dans ma vie j'ai
avancé être physicienne physique moderne
et particules puis le besoin de X et
tout là
dans mon cours le prof à mon âge
tout le monde est super brillant puis là
le premier examen que j'ai 57 je le ok
c'est possible pour une fille qui a été
14 ans sans aller à l'école enfin que je
vais poser plus de questions je vais
étudier plus ça va bien aller le la
matière devient de plus en plus dure la
deuxième examen que j'ai j'ai 38
j'ai jamais eu 38 dans ma vie plus là
my god je serai jamais capable d'étudier
je serai jamais capable de avoir mon
deck là c'est trop dur
les laboratoires comptaient pour
beaucoup puis les laboratoires sur le
cours de physique est en anglais chaîné
dans un cégep bilingue je me suis mis en
équipe avec une fille qui était comme
super bright qui a les maths là faisait
seul une table moi j'écrivais toutes les
rapports qui est en anglais avec mon
anglais était parfait on est des super
bonnes notes dans nos laboratoire etc ça
va monter ma note qui a l'examen final
on avait le droit d'un tchit que j'ai
écrit comme au point simple s'il y avait
eu un point 3 je l'aurais fait des deux
barres étaient pleines j'avais mis des
problèmes des formules j'ai passé mon
examen à 65 j'ai passé mon cours puis je
me souviens j'étais dans le Gym parce
que j'avais recommencé à m'entraîner
avec un entraîneur juste en c'est comme
en muscu
en fonctionnant fitness puis j'étais en
gym j'ai eu mon bulletin puis j'ai crié
là je me sentais tellement intelligente
qu'après ça j'ai fait de physique
mécanique là j'étais super correct là
j'ai une bonne note puis quand je suis
arrivé en physique moderne qui est le
plus facile et physique là mais quand
même ça prend un esprit de voir des
enfants dans ta tête quand j'ai tripé
Philomène j'ai fait mon cégep puis
j'étais à l'anniversaire
est-ce que je voulais utiliser le
cerveau puis surtout comment notre
nutrition peut affecter la production de
sérotonine et de dopamine et tout parce
que maintenant on sait que c'est ces
produits dans les intestins puis si tu
manges la junk ban tu seras pas dans un
bon mot là je voulais me spécialiser
là-dedans mais finalement je suis arrivé
j'ai eu un espèce d'épiphanie un moment
donné là j'ai 35 ans
jailli étant laboratoire je me fais
chier je mets en ligne pour une vie à
laboratoire que tu vas avoir des
résultats de tes études dans 20 ans
mais là ça fait cinq ans de ma vie que
je l'ai dit aux études j'ai choisi la
neurosciences plus j'ai eu le cœur brisé
maintenant si je
j'aime ça neurosciences mais c'est
vraiment plus comme un hobby quelque
chose que je vais toujours être
intéressé c'est pas ça ma job ça va être
quoi être ma job puis au même moment mon
chat était années ça job à lui tout le
temps était dans le milieu du fitness
c'est puis il voulait ouvrir un studio
puis là toi tu connaissais
l'entraînement tu vas être coach alors
ok j'ai fait ma formation là-dedans puis
ryancéré dans ta vie exacte puis j'avais
tellement peur au début d'être de
coacher c'est parce que mon expérience a
tellement mauvaise là-dedans que je me
disais c'est du groupe gogo fitness là
c'est pas des affaires olympiques c'est
des gens qui veulent être en forme puis
les entraînements qu'on a c'est top là
je l'ai en fait souvent j'en fais au
moins trois par semaine si tu peux
vraiment avoir un bon week-end mais
j'avais peur d'être trop trop
ça m'a ramené d'un autre porte un petit
peu par la porte d'à côté là dans le
sport puis je me suis rendu compte que
j'aime ça coacher ici c'est normal
en général tu sais versus ton expérience
puis je me suis rendu compte aussi puis
là je travaille avec un coach
qui est complètement l'opposé du premier
coach que j'avais puis je me dis ah ça
aurait pu être plus facile il y en a des
bons coachs
[Musique]
mais il faut pas non plus dissuader les
jeunes puis les parents d'envoyer leur
enfant dans le sport parce que les
conjoints vont être mauvais c'est pas
vrai j'en ai des millions des banques
ouais je réapproche tout en train de
réapprendre c'est quoi le sport en ce
moment c'est fou hein c'est fou puis tu
disais aussi sur le Podcast que j'ai
écouté que un type dans tout ça un de
tes plus grands regrets c'est de pas
savoir qu'est-ce que tu aurais pu se
passer avec avec ta carrière mettons
dans une autre une autre direction où
est-ce que tu aurais été à ton plein
potentiel
c'est quoi le sport mais en même temps
tu dis ah mais
je trouve ça Rachel aussi à ma
réhabituer à ça c'est accepter mes
limites comme aujourd'hui j'avais là je
l'ai dessus mes entraînements à ce
moment-là ça va super bien
mais ce matin je me suis réveillé je
suis là je suis fatigué
j'ai regardé
mais ma récupération
j'écoutais le podcast tantôt sur le et
tout ça c'est sûr que tu regardes ça
pitié moi je regarde pour les trends là
dedans donc quand tu vois que là tu es
pas capable de récupérer bien pour une
semaine deux semaines il faut que tu
regardes ça
fait que je regardais ça puis je fais là
j'ai besoin d'une semaine de repos tu
étais prévu pour la semaine d'après mais
là ça fait comme 4-5 jours que j'ai de
la je finis mes entraînements sur le cul
puis j'ai travaillé beaucoup il y a
fallu que je remplace parce que mes
coachs à l'école puis il y a d'autres
vies puis on les enfants c'est la vie
est rentrée en compte puis j'avais peur
de dire à mon coach ce matin si j'étais
là parce que j'ai appris à jamais même
si c'était fatigué c'était pas grave
quand tu es fatigué c'est parce que tu
penses au travers puis quand tu fais des
courses tu vas être fatigué il faut que
tu passes au travail puis je veux pas
savoir que tu es fatigué on s'entraîne
pareil même moi encore la même affaire
même si ça comme la merde pas grave il
faut que j'ai texté puis j'étais là et
ça va pas si j'ai envoyé un screenshot
de mes récupération puis là il était
comme fuck jeune ça fait trois semaines
que tu es dans le rouge dans le jaune là
c'est on prend la semaine récupération
maintenant c'est maintenant que tu as
besoin c'est super important
c'est ses affaires là que j'ai encore la
vieille la vieille cassette qui tourne
dans ma tête comme mon coach veut rien
savoir
mais c'est pas ça pendant toute facture
mais là ce matin quand j'étais assis
puis je buvais mon café que mon chum
dans ma face puis je suis là à stickman
je vais être en semaine de récupération
j'aille ça des semaines avec passion ça
me fait chier mais c'est il faut que tu
l'acceptes parce que sinon tu creuses un
trou là c'est fait tout en train de
naviguer ça c'est en tout cas super
intéressant de pas être à l'écoute de
son corps puis de juste dire on
s'entraîne nos barres on fait le même
entraînement c'est comme c'est une
absurdité dans le fond là
le but c'est que
ton corps ta machine soit le plus dans
le meilleur dans le meilleur état
possible dans la meilleure forme
possible de pas écouter ces signaux je
trouve aussi que souvent les athlètes
ils prennent ils prennent les en tout
cas moi dans mon cas puis dans ma
génération tu étais tellement pas tu
étais tellement pas à l'écoute de ton
corps tu sais la vieille école que tu
passes au travers puis tout ça puis oui
tu t’écris après tout que on transpose
ça dans notre vie aussi faites-le tu es
dans une situation où est-ce que tu es
hyper mal à l'aise que tu vas que tu as
dit oui à des affaires que tu veux
absolument pas faire qui tremble anxieux
qui sont comptés valeurs mais tu vas le
faire pareil parce que tu mélanges la
une voix qui dit this is not for you
fait les pas parce que tu es mal tu le
sais que c'est pas bon pour toi avec la
voix qui dit elle a tes jambes brûlentir
ralentir aussi
moi j'ai poussé dans des affaires dans
ma vie où j'ai enduré des affaires dans
ma vie que tu es
j'ai confondu les deux affaires fait que
la voix qui dit là tu es à
l'entraînement faut que tu fasses ton
pèse de X par km tu sais il faut que tu
fasses tant de watts en vélo quand tu as
mal aux jambes tu continues c'est
d'habitude c'est comme ça que tu serais
l'adaptation là il faut que la
mitochondrie a fait son travail
oui un apprentissage continu dans le
fond ça va être pour le reste de ta vie
mais en même temps le reste de la vie de
tout le monde c'est tout le monde doit
apprendre en continu mais j'imagine que
toi c'est comme
propulser au maximum ouais je pense que
les circonstances de ma vie on fait
comment donner c'est quand je suis sorti
de ma relation avec lui je me suis dit
je me suis juré une enfer puis que c'est
que j'allaite le plus authentique
possible puis des fois ça c'est 100%
puis des fois c'est 80% ou 90% ou 50%
mais c'est dans une dans une certaine
situation et avec moi-même d'être le
plus authentique possible puis de
toujours continuer
de découvrir comme personne faire des
affaires qui me font peur c'est
me pousser dans des places parce que je
suis inconfortable puis pas
inconfortable parce que c'est contre mes
valeurs mais c'est
l'entreprendre les trucs que je fais
avec avec Line cette année ça me donne
la chienne si j'ai jamais fait de ma vie
sur de Gravel bike dont un ultra
en Espagne
de Gravelle non-stop on va dormir mais
c'est le plus vite le cela qu'il fait en
le moins de temps possible qui gagne
tantôt on parlait de
pique tu disais que
en fait je te soumettais que tu avais
dit que tu es plus grand regret c'était
de pas avoir vu ton pic mais en Ultra le
pays qui est tort
physiologiquement je pense pas que tu
aies dépassé l'âge que tu pourrais
piquer en ultra
ultra trade
c'est un petit peu aussi pour ça que
j'ai choisi ça mais en même temps
de dire je veux être au top de ce que de
ce que je peux être en fait dans ce
sport là ce que tu veux
te pousser au maximum c'est ce truc là
mais je veux être capable de finir une
course puis me dire
j'aurais pas pu donner plus
dans ma première carrière j'étais
capable de le faire parce que je gagne
sous la peur c'est qu'est-ce qui a fait
de moi une machine c'était oui ma
motivation que j'avais depuis que je
suis tout petit mais c'est la
combinaison entre ma motivation et la
peur de qu'est-ce qui va m'arriver si je
gagne pas
de devoir gagner pour survivre qui a
fait que je gagnais puis l'année passée
quand j'ai recommencé les compétitions
j'étais tellement mêlée parce que là
cette peur-là elle est pilote il est
plus dans ma vie puis je me suis
retrouvé sur les lignes de départ puis
quand ça commençait à faire mal dans
certaines sections de la course pour
suivre les filles ou suivre le plateau
avec lequel j'étais
j'avais pas l'instinct de survie c'est
plus chaleur
moi je vais ralentir finalement pourquoi
je me ferais mal c'est supposé d'avoir
du fun puis du fun c'est pas avoir ta
face dans le guidon c'est mais là on
dirait j'ai perdu la connexion entre
pourquoi je le fais pour moi c'est pour
le fun puis pour le fan de me pousser
j'ai disconnecté là avec ça puis là mais
je vais travailler avec ça je suis
retourné voir mon psy on va travailler
sur ce la saison que ça vient parce que
je vais capable de trouver une nouvelle
sorte de motivation qui est pas la peur
quand j'avais 13 14 ans là dans les dans
mes dernières bonnes années d'enfants
avant que toute la merde arrive mais
c'est j'ai oublié là je pense que je
vais vite des aventures puis je vais
capable de me pousser au maximum pour
moi de voir c'est où puis écoute j'ai
peur maintenant un peu j'ai pas la
vitesse les courses de graves certaines
courses de Gravel que j'ai faites là
la route est pas fermée
des fois tu as des tournants ça va
contre le trafic parce que la ligne de
monde est là c'est un des trous tu as
différentes garnotes du sable de tout ça
puis écoute tu rentres dans les trous
des fois là
ça ça frappe tellement fort que tu te
demandes comment que tu as pu faire pour
ta roue explose pas puis là à la fin de
cette descente là que tu étais à 70 km/h
tu as un tournant en épingle puis tout
le monde s'en va la tête break la
dernière minute moi je suis obligé de
faire ça j'allais faire dans les pensées
et puis je non job que j'ai besoin de
bouger là je serai ben ça c'est bien
difficile de coacher puis de faire des
démons d'exercice si j'ai une jambe dans
le plâtre tu dis si je t'en appelle puis
aussi j'aime bien trop ça m'entraîner si
je serais malheureuse si j'étais blessé
en tout cas
c'est pas le sport la performance avant
tout le tirage d'autres choses qui
viennent
peser dans la balance et dans
l'équilibre exacte mais je me suis rendu
compte aussi à la fin de la saison que
pour moi avons du fun c'est aussi aller
fort puis j'ai été sur les fringues
toute la saison passée parce que je me
disais justement ben tu es juste posé de
façon pour le fun quand du fun tu as pas
mal aux jambes mais c'est pas ça non
que je trouve que j'ai fait pas mal de
progrès au travers de l'hiver on va voir
comment que ça sort en performance mais
c'est juste dans mes entraînements
d'intervalles que tu regardes
je veux pas le faire
mais là je passe vraiment bien au
travail c'est même quand j'ai des bouts
que j'ai pas fait de ma zone ou quelque
chose je le finis parce que je retrouve
mon moral tu sais qu'est-ce que l'année
passée j'avais beaucoup de difficultés
ton moteur est encore là tout le même
non
pour l'enlever tellement il me le tu
sais
je voulais qu'on parle un petit peu
parce que
d'autres en fait de la natation moi j'en
ai fait plus longtemps plus longtemps
que toi puis moi je veux dire des
situations
inacceptables j'en ai vu passer là puis
je me suis tu souvent comme tout le
monde qui était avec moi dans
l'entouragement qui voyait ses affaires
le se passer
des fois quand on prenait action mettons
pour ne pas se taire puis qu'on
reportait un comportement inacceptable
jusqu'au au sommet des preneurs de
décision
les personnes qui agissaient comme ça
c'est souvent des gens super
charismatiques qui sont capables de se
faire aimer dans les dans les
fédérations mettons ou dans les auprès
des parents auprès de
d'autres entraîneurs
dans une situation Paul fun qui vivent
des
niveaux de ce que toi tu as vécu mais
des situations pas le fun qui ou qui
voient des situations comme ça qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec ça comment qu'on fait
pour signaler ça pour essayer de changer
parce que c'est quand même culturel
c'est des coachs masculins qui ont une
emprise premièrement que ça se fait
aussi
féminin mais les exemples qu'on a c'est
plus des hommes qui qui mettent une
emprise vraiment toxique sur des
athlètes puis les histoires sortent
quasiment à toutes les semaines le titre
de scandale de fédération puis de trucs
complètement horribles qu'on lit le ne
serait-ce que dans la légion de sortir
là c'est des histoires d'horreur que tu
lis carrément mais il y a des gens qui
sont témoins de ça les gens qui en
parlent puis il y a rien qui se fait
comment on change cette culture là
mais la première chose
c'est l'éducation le plus que les
athlètes vont être éduqués le plus que
les parents ont été éduqués ils vont ils
vont spotter ça plus vite ils vont
comprendre qu'est-ce qui se passe mais
tu as raison en disant que quand tu t'en
vas voir quelqu'un pour te plaindre
souvent ça finit là c'est ça s'en va des
fois jusqu'en haut puis la personne en
haut va dire
maintenant on a ce portail au Québec là
et puis il y en a commencé à en avoir
plus des des
Alpes une agence là mais c'est des
organismes comme ça qui vont prendre ta
plainte ou ton cancer tes doutes ou
qu'est-ce que tu vis puis ils vont te
diriger vers la personne à qui parler
vers l'organisme à qui aller voir
dépendamment que c'est un parent un
arbitre un coach un athlète c'est parce
que le pire to
pearlines donc athlète athlète il y en a
beaucoup
[Musique]
pas bonne puis ça peut aussi c'est ça ça
peut être pas ça peut être pas une bonne
personne mais ça peut aussi pas
nécessairement être un bon coach puis
moi je donne souvent l'exemple
Bob Bowman qui est le qui était coach de
Michael Phelps
selon tous les paramètres
avec son son il s'améliore puis tout va
bien mais lui il est arrivé sur le deck
sur le bassin il y a vu Michael faible
sinon j'ai quand il y avait 11 ans il y
a peut-être toi tu as du talent tu sais
mais n'importe qui sera arrivé sur le
bassin en regardant Michael
serait devenu un coach des vingtaines de
fois médaillés d'or olympiques à cause
de la place souvent
la mauvaise personne est engagée à cause
de ses performances puis pourquoi que la
plainte va souvent jusqu'en haut dans la
Fédération puis que ça
ça meurt là c'est parce que
ici on des athlètes qui gagnent ils vont
avoir du budget pour l'année prochaine
ça c'est en train de changer là je parle
plus de mon expérience puis de bon mon
opinion puis qu'est-ce qu'on a vu aussi
généralement dans les médias sortir et
ça ça change mais je pense que c'est
important pour commencer à changer la
culture ben oui dénoncer n'est pas resté
dans notre fédération
allez voir ailleurs aller dénoncer à
dans un organisme comme Sportage c'était
ça le podcast que que j'écoutais le
conversation tête-à-tête avec toi
ça ça va nous sortir de
parce que encore une fois dans une
fédération si tu fais partie affaire tu
vois peut-être pas toutes les problèmes
ou tu dis ok
il gagne
ça veut dire que ça doit bien aller mais
c'est pas tout le temps ça fait que
ouais c'est sûr
il va falloir changer le modèle de
gagner à tout prix là puis que les
fédérations sportives fonctionnent
seulement si on des bonnes performances
puis ils vont avoir assez de gestes
seulement si les athlètes gang parce que
sur ça l'amène plein de problèmes c'est
pas la bonne façon selon moi
ultimate puisqu'on veut aussi c'est une
société qui est active et qui fait du
sport en général plutôt que juste une
petite proportion de ultra performant de
gagnant
il y a rien quand contre avoir des rêves
olympiques puis de viser la médaille
d'or je veux dire moi si j'avais la
capacité encore j'avais 20 ans ça serait
ça encore mon rêve je pense là ça va
toujours être à moi je vais être un
athlète ça fait partie de moi je suis
encore un athlète enfin qui a rien de
mal là-dedans il y a rien de mal à
vouloir gagner en tant qu'équipe pour
fédération au pays ou n'importe quoi
absolument pas mais si je pense que il y
a peut-être des façons alternatives d'y
arriver là puis là tu sais parce que
mettons aussi l'objectif de mort de
gagner le car va vers l'objectif de
devrait toujours être le plaisir de le
faire puis je suis persuadé que un
athlète qui a du fun va être meilleur
que l'inverse c'est je suis persuadé que
moi mettons là c'est mes meilleures
années de natation c'est quand j'avais
du plaisir à nager j'avais du plaisir du
plaisir à faire mon programme j'avais du
plaisir à être là quand l'entraînement
puis au contraire mes pires années
c'était quand je le mettais de la
pression pour les essais olympiques de
Londres par exemple ou est-ce que là
c'était juste ça juste ça il y avait
plus rien de fun là j'ai encore
d'entraînement dans des places
paradillac il y a pas une journée que
genre j'étais capable d'apprécier ce que
j'étais
en Martinique
la plus belle piscine que je suis allée
là de toute ma vie genre
olympique puis tout ce que je me
rappelle de ça c'est que être nerveux
puis vouloir réussir mes temps puis
comme puis il y avait aucun plaisir
là-dedans versus mes deux derniers
entraînement où est-ce que c'était plus
dans le plaisir ben j'ai des excellents
souvenirs ça a été mes meilleures années
de natation
moi j'ai plein d'années j'ai blanc de
mémoire il y a plein d'enfants je me
souviens pas je pourrais pas dire
si je me souviens pas beaucoup des
Olympiques j'ai aïssu à aux Olympiques
puis j'aurais pas dû à hier ça mais
c'est parce que j'avais trop de pression
c'est ça j'avais trop de pression j'ai
pas eu le droit d'aller à la cérémonie
d'ouverture
[Musique]
que je me dis que je me souviens d'avoir
franchi la ligne mais toute qu'est-ce
qui est arrivé après avant puis après
j'ai aucune idée c'est puis j'aimerais
savoir c'est souvenir là mais c'est
parce que j'avais pas de fun j'étais
trop poignée dans qu'est-ce qu'elle est
arrivé puis qu'est-ce qu'il fallait que
je fasse pour gagner parce que ça
c'était mon ticket pour pour avoir le
plus de calme dans ma vie c'était sûr
je regrette ça j'étais allé dans les
super pays c'est ça en plus le cyclisme
c'est comme un des sports où est-ce que
tu vas dans les endroits les plus fous
là
si vous êtes témoin
de quelque chose qui vient vous chercher
vous ça c'est pas correct
en plus portail appelé n'importe quoi
d'autre qui aide les athlètes ou tu sais
c'est important d'en parler parce que si
on si on on ferme les yeux ou on met
notre flash notre truc là comme les
chevaux ont
ça va retarder le changement
le sport vraiment du retard sur d'autres
domaines de la société là-dessus j'ai
l'impression que comme autant que
d'avoir fait du sport je veux dire ça a
été la meilleure chose à ma vie et puis
je veux dire ça le forger les personnes
que je suis ça m'a appris la personne
errance le travail l'esprit d'équipe
c'est plein d'affaires plein de super
positif mais en même temps je compte il
y a comme tous les Allemands aussi pour
qu'il puisse avoir
des de l'abus qui peut savoir tu sais
c'est comme justement on a parlé
l'athlète le jeune athlète et pas
encouragé à dire comment qu'il sent à
dire que si je dis qu'il est fatigué là
il passe pour celui qui se plaint si ils
étaient donc justement parler de ce que
tu vis de ce que tu ressens puis là puis
en plus dis-moi à part mes parents la
personne qui a eu le plus de
de pouvoir puis de contrôler puis
d'importance dans ma vie c'était ma
coach au secondaire et puis aujourd'hui
merci on avait une coach qui était
bienveillante qui était appelé maman
littéralement presque devenu son R5 j'ai
appelé maman par comme sans vouloir le
dessin et maman c'est quoi le titre
mais
une figure quasiment maternelle mais tu
sais tu remplaces par quelqu'un qui qui
est mal intentionné puis c'est vraiment
une recette
c'est vraiment je les ingrédients pour
une catastrophe mais ça je pense qu'on
peut le retrouver aussi en société dans
dans d'autres choses tu sais dans
d'autres milieux qui sont hyper
performants aussi je pense c'est pas
propre au sport mais c'est certain que
le sport ça le toutes les bons
ingrédients pour venir chercher ça parce
que en tant qu'athlète je veux pas tu es
vulnérable le plus en plus que tu
performes le plus en plus que tu es
reconnu pour tes performances donc tu as
personnalité c'est face peu c'est ton
identité devient être athlète et bien
performer
souvent je retombe sur les qualités que
j'ai appris dans le sport pour passer au
travers de ma vie tu sais que je suis
quand même grave
si je veux juste aborder
le sujet du doping dans le sport avant
qu'on avant qu'on termine
est-ce que c'était parce que la
perspective que moi j'avais quand ton
histoire est sortie puis ça à peu près
des années que l'histoire de lens and
Trump est sorti aussi est-ce que dans le
Ploton c'était vraiment répandu ou
c'était des cas isolés chez les femmes
ou chez les hommes
je pense que chez les hommes j'ai
l'impression que c'était vraiment
répandu oui chez les femmes j'en ai
aucune idée
toute ma vie enfin que j'avais même pas
une amie dans le plateau mes coéquipiers
je pouvais même pas habiter avec elle
quand on était encore d'entraînement moi
j'avais ma place avec l'entraîneur puis
d'acide c'est j'ai côtoyé des filles
extraordinaires que j'ai aucune idée
sont qui j'ai jamais eu une vraie
conversation avec les autres c'était
tout le temps facture j'en ai aucune
idée
en passant juste une petite parenthèse
pour les gens qui nous écoutent si vous
êtes parents puis que votre jeune va
dans une chambre d'hôtel avec son coach
non c'est quand c'est tout de suite ça
c'est le plus gros nombre peu importe si
c'est le coach le mieux intentionné de
la planète Terre
isolé aux compétitions ou au match ou
n'importe quoi que il est tout le temps
à côté de ses coéquipiers ou qu'il y ait
tout le temps le coach va y parler plus
ou c'est non il y a quelque chose qui va
mais pour en revenir
je ne sais pas chez les hommes c'est sûr
que dans surtout en cyclisme que c'était
très très répandu mais je vais amener la
discussion dans un autre point je trouve
qu'on a toujours l'impression que le
dopage c'est le modèle land Samsung
il y avait une personne en tête de sub
et que c'était fait pour gagner puis
tout le monde devait le faire c'était un
choix mais dans la majorité des cas de
dopage c'est pas ça c'est plus sans dire
que ils ont vécu des abus comme moi j'ai
vécu il y a eu des certaines situations
où est-ce que l'athlète a été poussée
là-dedans et puis là ben les gens vont
peut-être dire ouais mais elle a vu
c'était comment l'entreprise mais c'est
pas sûr de toute façon je pense qu'on
est rendu loin
du doping en tant que tel mais je pense
que la majorité des athlètes ont pas eu
le choix de dire non ce n'est pas un
choix puis je trouve que le système
antidopage
parce qu'on a encore dans le système
antidopage le
la vision que les gens qui utilisent des
produits dopant c'est des doppers c'est
des mauvaises personnes c'est comme un
peace of chit puis on a pas de place où
est-ce qu'on pourrait aller puis se
confier ou aller avouer ouais c'est ça
puis je vais vous raconter une histoire
là-dessus si on a le temps là moi en
2004 je suis dans une coupe du monde en
Europe puis ils viennent prendre un test
de sang le matin
et je m'en vais déjeuner le téléphone
sonne à l'hôtel c'est pour moi la
coacher répond il faut que je m'en aille
mon test oh mon échantillon a et plus
haut que la limite enfin que ce soit un
test de sang et vérifie ton image de
crit pour les femmes je pense que la
limite c'est 47 je me souviens bien les
hommes c'est 50 les femmes c'est 47 donc
le ton pourcentage de globules rouges
dans ton sang
puis ils me disent ah il faut absolument
que nos laboratoire il faut ouvrir ton
ton échantillon B ton test est super
haut viens temps enfin que là moi je
panique si on s'en va c'est comme deux
heures avant le départ de la course
j'arrive là-bas je demande pour les
résultats puis le gars me dit bon les a
pas les résultats on a juste vu le
numéro flasher sur le
la machine
puis l'imprimante est brisée enfin que
on a vu que c'était comme 50 mais j'ai
pas la preuve je peux pas te le donner
ils m'ont enfermé dans une chambre tout
seul deux heures avant le début de la
course avec deux gars
deux gros gars qui m'ont complètement
détruit me poser des questions
ils me disait on va trouver on sait que
tu prends des produits dopantes et tout
le monde ils m'ont grillé au maximum
pendant au moins 30 minutes pour me
faire avoir
puis j'ai rien dit je suis sorti de là
après 30 minutes la cogner la porte on a
sorti ils m'ont donné mon résultat en
papier
maltais comme magiquement puis mon
hématocrite était comme à 43 c'est
impossible mais ils m'ont fait devenir
là pour vraiment pour essayer de
m'intimider pour que je parle mais
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que ce
serait passé si la même situation mais
là j'ai deux femmes ou deux gars super
fins qui me disent écoute John on a dit
on suspect que tu dopes on suspecte que
ça vienne de ton environnement
on aimerait ça t'aider c'est pas besoin
de parler de suite mais on voulait te
faire venir ici on voulait te dire que
si jamais tu veux avouer oui de faire
une suspension mais pendant ta
suspension on va te faire travailler on
va se faire travailler en éducation en
outre tu vas avoir un salaire parce que
écoute la majorité des groupes des
filles qui ont pris des produits au pain
et ont des familles on est maison des
fois ils ont été dans pays ont des
fédérations que les poussent à faire ça
ils ont aucune et porte de sortie c'est
sûr que tu vas pas dire allô je me doute
parce que là
l'omerto je veux dire c'est c'est
on va rester là il y aura pas personne
qui va venir j'avais été j'avais fait
face à deux personnes comme ça tu
m'avais dit si jamais tu veux revenir au
sport après ta suspension tu vas être
capable de revenir au sport ok c'est sûr
que là tu vas avoir des tests plus
souvent à faire mais on va t'aider mais
on veut que tu sentes absolument
confortable que si jamais tu es dans une
situation dopage et que c'est pas toi
qui a décidé on veut savoir on va
t'aider sur un salaire tu vas tu es pas
de mauvaise personne tu es tout le monde
personne
j'aurais probablement parlé
s'arrête tout de changer parce que
j'étais prête à parler dans ce temps-là
tu sais ça faisait des années que je
vivais mon calvaire j'ai été pris juste
l'année d'après c'est puis déjà dans ce
temps-là je me dis Asti si je peux me
faire attraper par un short par une
blessure belles choses que je puisse
arrêter mon fucking de sport
je pense qu'on devrait faire preuve de
beaucoup plus de compassion et surtout
dans les programmes d'antiopage puis un
autre affaire aussi que c'est un moment
donné il va falloir se poser la question
elle est où la responsabilité
sociale des journalistes ou des gens qui
sont proches des athlètes puis qui se
rendent compte que c'est un enfant c'est
en bas de 18 ans qui vit des affaires ou
qui prend des produits dopant on est
encore des enfants enfin c'est quoi on
va à United nation on va à Charles
carever protection c'est un moment donné
pour des gens qui sont en bas de 18 ans
puis qui vivent toute seule puis qui
prennent des produits dopants comme moi
ça m'est arrivé depuis l'âge de 16 ans
je veux dire j'étais un kit là si on
maintenant je regarde des jeunes de 16
ans c'est comme
thématures
c'est pas vécu assez pour prendre des
décisions aussi
drastiques aussi importantes puis de
subir les conséquences aussi tes
décisions que tu prends tu as pas les
outils pour dire non plus c'est pour
prendre une décision
qu'est-ce qui est un bon coach qu'est-ce
qui est un mauvais coach je dis
qu'est-ce que je me fais proposer si tu
vraiment pour ma carrière aussi pour ma
carrière de l'autre personne tu sais je
veux dire enfin que je trouve que
pour Pascal dopage en lit minéraux
jamais là
mais si on veut
l'améliorer il va falloir commencer à
avoir plus de compassion puis avoir des
systèmes en place pour que les athlètes
puissent aller
se confier puis c'est là qu'on va
trouver c'est qu'on va être capable de
démanteler le système là c'est pas c'est
pas comme ça
c'est quoi la sanction qui va au coach
versus
hmm je pense pas qu'il aille il y en a
qui doit en avoir certainement mais tu
sais moi mon coach a été banni à vie
parce que il y a donné des produits
dopant une mineure mais ça c'est banni à
vie mais c'est banni à vie dans le sport
olympique il y a peut-être il habite
encore à Arizona
l'équipe de sport de du High School
là-bas
les régulations c'est pas partout son
nom est pas dans un database
fait que il doit avoir des sanctions
mais souvent c'est l'athlète ce qui est
puni puis tu dis que à ce moment-là si
tu avais été approché comme ça peut-être
que tu aurais que tu aurais parlé puis
quand c'est sorti quand tu as été pris
finalement t'étais nié pendant pendant
un bout jusqu'à temps que finalement tu
parles ça a été quoi en fait le déclic
pourquoi à ce moment-là tu as décidé
d'avouer parce que quand je n'y est
parce que j'étais encore avec lui puis
lui s'en plaint c'était que la
suspension de deux ans que je continue
le sport
je peux pas vivre ma vie comme ça fait
que quand j'ai décidé de me sauver ben
c'est là que j'ai décidé je suis comme
ok
je prends ma première décision en tant
qu'adulte puis encore une fois dans ma
tête j'avais
si j'ai des enfants je veux pas que mes
enfants pensent outils qui qui
grandissent avec l'idée à ma mère elle a
été accusée dopage mais c'est pas vrai
j'aurais jamais été capable d'élever des
enfants avec des mensonges j'aimais
mieux partir clean
il voit que je me suis planté puis que
j'ai avoué qui prennent mon expérience
comme une vraie expérience pas comme une
rentrée encore j'étais plus capable de
vivre avec les mantries taxi tu as été
seul déclic j'étais comme moi qui est le
slip de lui c'est ma fucking vie je fais
ça
puis tu disais plutôt
la croix du dopage tu vois la portée
toute ta vie tu sais puis que intervenu
ici
tu avais pas peur du jugement des gens
mais est-ce que est-ce que tu le
véhicules est-ce que les gens sont
encore accrochés cette histoire-là
est-ce que tu ressens encore j'ai jamais
eu personne qui est venu dans ma face
puis il m'a dit toi tu es une épaisse
jamais jamais jamais c'est sûr que là si
je me mets à lire toutes les
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
en ligne coupe de bombe je suis là oh
right c'est cool
les accusations d'habits sexuel c'est
belle la première fois que je vois ça
comme excuse pour le dopage
mais je dois dire que les gens ont été
vraiment très gracefall et gentil en
pratique avec moi en personne ça c'est
quand même aussi une leçon par rapport
[Musique]
à la vitesse à laquelle les gens passent
à autre chose ces mettons une
controverse quand ça t'arrive à toi mais
j'en ai vécu quelques petites pas à la
hauteur de la tienne mais de faire comme
c'est toute ma vie au complet fait que
moi je pense qu'à ça c'est moi c'est
tout le monde pense tout le temps juste
à ça mais le monde t'es le personnage
principal de ta propre vie mais tu es un
personnage secondaire en tabarque la vie
des autres
tu reviens comme trois ans après le
monde soit il s'en rappelle c'est que
nous on s'en rappelle mais genre après
ça tu as appris un million d'affaires
qui a amené à ça puis c'est juste des
informations de conserver une haine pour
que
aller finalement
que ça a rien à fondre souvent on a
quand même plus peur la réaction des
autres que les gens écoutent on pense
que les gens pensent juste à ça mais
c'est vers vivre leur vie
on est des champions nos pantalons mais
en dehors de nos pantalons là c'est
comme tout le monde alors leurs
histoires aussi là
comment comment te trouver
en finissant le film la petite reine
contribué
puis c'est bon c'est une version je dis
souvent que c'est une version piji de ma
vie là c'est pas 18 ans et plus là c'est
vraiment la version facile puis quand tu
dis que tu l'auras raconté en fait à
cette époque-là je te racontais pas tout
j'ai tout raconté moi parce que
de ton histoire complète
je rentrais pas mal dans les détails
parce que quand ils m'ont vu à
l'émission Enquête avec Alain Gravel ils
m'ont contacté comme tout de suite après
puis j'étais encore hyper fâché c'est
mes émotions étaient tellement la
surface que c'était comme je pense qu'il
y avait une petite partie de moi qui
pensait ça marchera jamais le fait mais
oui c'est sur ma vie ma vie franchement
c'est de la merde
j'étais j'avais du venez qui sortait le
contre le coach de truffe à pas mal sur
que j'étais allée loin je sais que j'ai
parlé des abus sexuels et tout ça les
autres qui ont modifié dans le film et
tout
enfin que oui probablement qu'il y a
quelque part il y a un tape de moi qui
torche là il va assembler mais
finalement fait que tu avais aimé le
résultat final le film c'est à part être
PJ est-ce que c'était une bonne
représentation d'après toi je pense que
c'est une excellente représentation du
malaise de la première scène jusqu'à la
fin là du des sous-entendus puis du
stress et de la paranoïa que je vivais
dans cet état là
ça c'est excellent puis là le reste des
affaires c'est bon j'ai jamais frappé
personne
il y a des trucs qui sont qui sont plus
romancés mais tu sais quand je revenais
à Montréal c'est vrai que j'ai travaillé
dans les cuisines j'ai travaillé dans un
CHSLD comme aide alimentaire c'est il y
a des petits points là-dedans attaquer
oui ça fonctionne mais c'est vraiment et
on fait une histoire basée sur là c'est
pas c'est pas biographique mais je
trouvais qu'on fait un bon mix de
trucs dark puis de belles émotions aussi
parce que c'est le fun gagné là j'ai
aimé ça gagner la Coupe du Monde
au travail il y avait des j'avais des
pochettes de maman d'émotions que
j'étais là c'est jamais seul
c'est juste dommage que Patrice robita
qui est un de mes acteurs préférés joue
le rôle tellement détestable
merci beaucoup pour ton temps puis ton
ouverture c'est super intéressant